a bipartisan commission created by
President Trump to fight drug addiction
will meet today for the first time
according to preliminary data overdoses
killed more than 59 thousand Americans
last year that is a record it is also
more than car crashes or gun violence
Tony D Coppola met with one Texas family
who lost two sons this year to the
opioid crisis Tony good morning good
morning Gilbert and Kim Freeman lost
their youngest sons to heroin first on
Valentine's Day and then on Mother's Day
now they're warning parents to stay
vigilant and calling on lawmakers to
rethink the war on drugs we didn't
really set out to have five children for
nearly 50 years together Gilbert and Kim
Freeman have been making memories in
North Texas you just think these are
your beautiful children and they're
gonna turn out to be great at what point
did you start to worry about drugs as
soon as they were in high school all
three of their boys hunt Jack and Ross
struggled with addiction it started with
alcohol
then cocaine then heroin I kept thinking
that I was going to fix them that if I
if I got him in a different school I'd
have been the route rehab and whatever
it was and I just didn't have an
understanding of the power of that drug
the youngest brother hunt overdosed more
than a dozen times he was walking the
edge all the time so close to death he
died on Valentine's Day at 26 you know
once you go down that road of taking
heroin I mean ever turning back
obviously is almost impossible for so
many people and it took us took me way
too long to figure that out
Jack relapsed after Hunt's death and the
morning after Mother's Day he didn't
show up for work you know when I kept
calling Jack and calling Jack and I
remember sitting in my car just think
she's please be okay just we can't do
this again Ross the oldest brother
stopped his father from going inside
Jack's apartment there's nothing quite
as terrifying as hearing a parent's
scream that they make when they know
that their child is dead it's it's the
saddest noise
I've ever heard and we weren't near
finished grieving for hunt you know cuz
that was the new experience we weren't
finished grieving at all I felt like I
had even started grieving rather than
hide their pain the Freeman's have
decided to talk about it
publishing an obituary with a picture of
the boys they lost it was a cute little
picture of Jack and hunt when they were
together
holding each other and that's how I like
to think that that that's where they are
knew the Freeman's believe that
legalization of drugs not stronger
enforcement they have saved their family
people are going to use drugs they're
going to get high and you know we just
better face it that our war isn't
winning at all there's got to be a
different strategy that how you feel as
well every culture has used drugs for
centuries if it's regulated that might
be an answer the Freeman's hoped that by
sharing their story they can save
another parents child I mean I'd love to
just curl in a ball and cry and do
nothing but that's not life that's not
living if I want to honor their lives I
would put some energy into something and
this is what we've chosen there are some
happier details here the Freeman's
oldest son Ross is getting married this
September 6 years after recovering from
a heroin addiction himself and it's the
kind of success story that the Freeman's
hope other families can share Gayle I'm
so glad that story is ending on a happy
note but that's tough the fact that
they're sharing it though I think is
very important it'll be interesting to
see if this Commission in the DC
environment right now in a bipartisan
way can get can get something done'
rethink the way this is looked at we
will be surprised at their position they
want it legalized that's interesting
thank you Tony